ce sera une grande première au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines un
match de d1 féminine de handball va être
organisée le samedi 25 mars dans la
structure avec au programme une
rencontre de haut niveau entre les clubs
d'ici paris et de brest
là on est ravis d'accueillir du monde on
espère après pour acteurs du basket du
volley et voilà c'est l'idée c'est
vraiment d'inscrire cette salle qui a
une salle d'une 6500 personnes on
m'accepte une capacité maximale en fait
de pouvoir l'optimiser et d'utiliser
comme une vraie salle de sports et
spectacles
j'ai encore un peu de mal à me projeter
parce que c'est un peu grand et c'est un
peu lointains par rapport aux places des
spectateurs donc
c'est pas c'est excitant et en même
temps ça fait un peu peur la rencontre
sera avant tout un choc du championnat
entre les deux co leaders de la division
des stars du handball féminin seront sur
la feuille de match parmi les joueuses
on retrouvera la demi centre steen oft
dalle médaillé de bronze aux derniers jo
avec la norvège est championne du monde
ça va être très très cool c'est un match
très important pour nous j'ai bien joué
des matches comme ça aussi la pression
augmente c'est ça qu'on connaît du monde
il devrait y en avoir l'objectif annoncé
ce mardi 7 février en conférence de
presse et de battre le record de 5100 27
places vendues pour un match de d1
féminine
pour atteindre ce chiffre les premiers
tickets seront accessibles à 5 euros
bah déjà j'espère que le record sera
atteint en tant que joueuse bas c'est
une énorme
c'est un énorme événement donc
a dit être et en même temps on a un peu
d'appréhension parce qu'on sait qu'on
sera vu par beaucoup de personnes et on
sait qu'il faudra faire une belle
prestation
en attendant ce match de gala les
joueuses d'ici paris se sont déjà
familiarisés avec l'enceinte sportive en
s'essayant aux traditionnels baptêmes de
piste le handball et le vélodrome une
histoire qui roule déjà